my name is PewDiePie I am a maverick I
am a savage I am a legend I am a madman
you never know what I'm going to do next
[Applause]
[Music]
I am a mad lad so I told Dean to lay
down on the floor he actually did it
absolute madman I may be a mad black but
I will never be as mad as Dean just
laying on the floor watching the French
intro without clapping absolute madman
no he did not absolutely
I can't help it you did what I do weird
things in the holidays like eat bowls of
pasta random absolute randomly I can
keep up with it absolute savage absolute
maverick someone call the police this
dude at the noodle place is really about
to yell out order number 69 and I'm
about to f'ing chanting that's a goddamn
sex number and he's about to yell it
[Music]
feminist vegan says meat is bad then
Jesse Watters whips out a steak and eats
it right in front of her absolute mad
lab that is crazy
Matty D raps a well-known established
mad land that I can only show my utmost
respect for what did he do this time
what's he do mattock me laughs what kind
of crazy thing did he do takes a lot of
hard work and focus in the studio but in
the end it's all worth it hashtag
8:24 that's like way past his bedtime I
bet you ain't seven but you didn't
actually read the whole number so I'm
guessing you didn't see the ladder in it
you just went back and checked and saw
that I lied muhaha Neil deGrasse Tyson I
occasionally free swivel 360 degrees in
those oversized chairs doing important
organs
oh yeah
turns out the madman got the madla dad
where are them
Isis Seward's
literally me every single day I'm like I
arm slightly higher than normal and then
I think to myself
sure hope there was an Isis someone put
on their on their car that they paid
peace an absolute mad land the blessed
day I wore a thong on my head at
Coachella and literally no one noticed
mad women or is it still mad land mad
Wham absolute mad when she wore it maybe
maybe just maybe no one wanted to point
out cuz it wasn't really that funny and
pretty disgusting to be honest an
absolute outrageous prankster pranks is
entire face perfect 8 Meghan plugs naked
look smiley face troll things from
Google Image Search absolutely no screen
for brewing for did not you spend $35 at
McDonald's at 3 a.m. absolute MATLAB
respect my friend is so drunk he's
literally cleaning my room
magnets bottom you can't clean someone
else's my number one rule I worked at
Arby's for a summer and put at least one
curly fry in every order of normy fries
is he crazy
oh my god I stayed up till 10:00 on a
school night just to watch this trailer
hashtag Star Wars
sometimes mad laughs gotta make
sacrifices for their mannery true mad
land to all the people who never thought
I could do it
hashtag thank you what are you doing
just ordering a grain of rice from
Chinese restaurant parentheses you can't
just do that
you can't you sort of one absolute
madman no no the mad Ladd stretches all
across the world
I always listen to Eminem man not care
about monetizing his videos on YouTube
absolute havoc this guy's insane can
someone stop him he used to fu emoji
that's like forbidden in most countries
it's illegal in at least fifty four
states I eat my ice cream with a fork
what the fork we cut on a random puss
how will they know how to get back do
they even know where the bus is going
my dad's playing rocket League while I'm
standing absolute madman I can't even
tell if he's standing or is this cringe
got a picture I mean get de twig Airport
holding shitty Rock vodka another one at
the airport another one another Airport
one mad land you can't just take
pictures with the alcohol that's the
thing about Mad less they don't care
about the states they don't care if you
might go to jail forever they have to
express their mad lad why yes I am
having some milk and bailers with dark
chocolate truffle at 11:30 p.m. and I
think I realized I think it finally sunk
in I will never be a mad lad there's no
way I can be this maverick and Savage
damn it you know what if I want to be a
mad land there's nothing that can stop
me thank you for watching this video if
you're a mad lad leave a like and if
you're a mad man or a man or anything
leave a like just leave a like and
subscribe we're almost at 60 million
subscribers if if we hit 60 million
subscribers I'm going to shave one hair
of my beard
madmen out
[Music]
[Applause]